it was the news no one wanted to hear
but everyone had feared a missing
two-month-old baby found dead in a
wooded area close to where its parents
were arrested less than 48 hours before
a crime scene is in place and work at
the location is expected to continue for
some time I recognize the impact this
news will have on the many people who
have been following the story closely
and can assure them that we will do
everything we possibly can to establish
what has happened
Constance Martin and Mark Gordon have
been on the Run since the 5th of January
after their car was found abandoned at
the side of the motorway after a tip-off
from a member of the public they were
finally arrested in Brighton on Monday
night
a vast search for their missing newborn
was launched as specialist teams scoured
water and Woodland I understand that the
conclusion of this search will be
heartbreaking for the local community
and The Wider public
who have been impacted by and so
supportive of this search and the
investigation from the outset the couple
were initially arrested on suspicion of
child neglect later changing to gross
negligence manslaughter police
investigators have now had an
application granted to extend
questioning by 36 hours officers said
that the couple had refused to tell them
where the baby was but after a vast
unextensive search spanning 90 square
miles the remains of a baby were
discovered not far from here near to
where its parents were finally detained
after 54 days on the Run
Central to the police hunt for the
couple over the last seven weeks was to
find the baby that search has now ended
in tragedy and a post-mortem is expected
in the coming days Adele Robinson Sky
News Brighton